two blocks are connected by a string of
negligible mass that passes over
massless pulleys that turn with
negligible friction as shown in the
figure above we see that there
the mass m2 of block 2
is greater than the mass one of block
one the blocks are released from rest so
let's just really quick think about what
we think is going to happen here
block two has a larger mass they're
connected by this this string and pulley
system here well if it has a larger
master in the same gravitational field
it's going to have a larger weight and
so the weight pulling down on block 2 is
going to be larger than the weight
pulling down on block one and so you're
going to have block 2 accelerating
downwards
you're going to have block 2
accelerating downwards
and block 1 is going to accelerate
upwards with the same magnitude
so block 1 is going to accelerate
upwards and so with that just intuition
of what we think is going to happen here
let's try to tackle part a of this so
they tell us the dots below these dots
represent the two blocks so this
represents block one this represents
block two draw free body diagrams
showing and labeling the forces not
components exerted on each block draw
the relative lengths of all vectors to
reflect the relative magnitudes of all
forces
all right so let's think about what are
all the forces acting on each of these
blocks well for each of these blocks
you're going to have the force of
gravity you're going to have the weight
of the blocks acting on them so for
example
this first block m1
m1 i'll draw it here first
what is the force of gravity going to be
the force of gravity is going to be its
mass
times the gravitational field
now what is going to be the force of
gravity on block 2.
well it's going to be larger than that
so let me just draw it like this
so the force of gravity is going to be
m2 times g how did i know it was going
to be larger well m2 has a larger mass
and we are in the same gravitational
field
now we're not done there no we're not
done yet because now we also have the
upward pulling force of the tension in
the string
and we could think about what the
magnitude of that we know that the we
know that the tension is going to be
pulling upwards on both of the blocks
but let's think about what its magnitude
is going to be in order for block 1 to
accelerate upwards which is of our
intuition as to what would happen the
tension the force of the tension has to
be larger the magnitude of the tension
has to be larger than the magnitude of
the weight now
in in order for block 2 to accelerate
downwards the magnitude of the tension
has to be less than the downward force
of gravity the upward force of tension
has to be less than the downward force
of gravity so the magnitude of the tent
of the tension is going to be in between
the magnitudes of these two weights so
let me draw that
so the magnitude of the tension is going
to be larger than m1g but smaller than
m2g so maybe like that so that is
tension right there
and
and whoops
and you're going to have on this side
you're going to have the same
magnitude of your tension pulling
upwards
but it's now less than the weight which
means that the block is going to
accelerate downwards and we know that
these two tension the magnitudes of
these tension vectors are going to be
the same because of the magnitude of the
tension throughout this entire string is
going to be the same when you think
about tension this pulling force you can
think about what's happening at an
atomic or molecular level
is these are the you know the covalent
bonds pulling on each other at an atomic
level throughout the entire string and
we look at it on a macro level we view
that as tension so there you have it
i've i've drawn the forces on them but i
haven't drawn them in the right place i
need to draw them on on this i need to
draw them right over here so let me draw
that i can actually draw a little bit
more precisely because they gave us
these these lines
so
on block one i have the weight so that
is
m
one g
i also have the tension i'll make that
two of these lines tall
so
i also have the tension
now block two i have the same tension
or i've say magnitude of tension i
should say it's now it's also pulling
upwards
so
tension
and i have its weight which is going to
be larger than the tension
so
its weight i'll make it three of these
lines
so the way i've drawn it m2 would have
to have be three times m2 would have to
be three times larger than m1 the way
i've drawn it they don't tell us that
but they tell us that m2 is larger so
this seems to be right and we just want
to get our intuition here since our
since our tension our upward force is
larger than our downward force you're
gonna have a net upward force which is
going to accelerate block one up and
here you're gonna have a net downward
force which is going to accelerate block
2 down
which which is in line with our
intuition because block 2 weighs more
than block 1.